500 years ago,...
...the Inca people of Peru chose a beautiful teenage girl as their princess.
The Incas needed to make a religious sacrifice.
They chose their princess as the sacrifice.
They put her in a sarcophagus while she was still living.
Then, they left her forever.
Rodney's disappeared,...
...he didn't come home last night.
The police are looking for him.
Rodney's body looked so dead.
Yeah, 500 years dead. But why?
Hello, I'm Ampata.
Hi, I'm Buffy Summers...
...and these are my friends Xander and Willow.
I'm sorry we're so late.
Pleased to meet you.
I have something to tell you and it's a little bit scary.
What is it?
Well, I really like you.
Will you come to the dance with me?
What girl travels with a mummy and doesn't bring makeup?
Ampata is our mummy!
And our killer!
Giles, she's at the dance with Xander!